fallibalism is the stance that we can
always be objectively wrong
this means there is something to be
objectively wrong about
so it implies realism while at the same
time rejecting relativism the idea there
is no way of being objectively wrong and
also dogmatism the idea that sometimes
about some things at least one cannot
possibly be wrong because one has found
the final truth this idea that it is
possible to get to the final truth that
the truth is Manifest as Carl poppa said
only ever leads to tyranny that may seem
like a bold claim and it may be but that
does not make it any less true and yes I
said true there because there is nothing
about this stance that rejects truth the
opposite it is just that we can never
know we have found the truth but our
best explanations must contain truth